Catherine is with us in Connecticut hi
Catherine how are you let's try again I
didn't hit the button hard enough there
it goes Catherine how are you I'm doing
great Dave how are you I think I'm
getting better how can I help I just had
a question I have some family members
who live in Virginia right now they're
thinking about moving back to
Connecticut to be near the family and
they think they're gonna vent when they
get here I was wondering if you could
tell me whether it's a terrible idea or
not to rent to them if I owned a house
and rent it out to them no it's not a
terrible idea at all
doing business with the family can be
perfectly fine what you have to do
though is you have to have very
uncomfortably clear conversations ahead
of time setting the table okay and it
sounds like this
when you move into the house and I'm
dealing with you there I am NOT your
cousin I'm your landlord right and you
have the right as the tenant to expect
your landlord to do the repairs to do
the pay the taxes and keep the insurance
on the property and do the things that a
normal landlord does mm-hmm
that's all and I have the right as the
landlord to expect you to pay your rent
early or on time and if you don't you
know what the landlord does they evict
you okay and so when we're together
talking about the property you're
wearing a hat on top of your head that
says tenant I'm wearing one that says
landlord when we're together at
Grandma's house for Thanksgiving we're
wearing hats that say cousins right but
you don't get to play the cousin card as
a way to not pay your rent okay and you
don't worry about like them asking for
like something unreasonable to be done
and me say no and that affecting the
relationship kind of the same way that
you kind of advise people not to lend
money to family right well a lending
money to family I would never
because it does change the relationship
but you can have a you can I've got my
grown children which always thinks an
oxymoron when I say that but my grown
the Ramsey mice my children they're my
children but they're grown work here and
when they're here at work they don't get
to give unreasonable asks for
unreasonable things any more than
anybody else that works here can and I
can I don't get to be unreasonable with
them as their CEO I treat them with the
same dignity I would any other team
member and no more no less and so as
long as we have that clear that this is
a landlord-tenant relationship and you
do not get to play the family card in
order to be unreasonable or to not pay
your rent or to be a jerk or you know
I'm gonna treat you fine I'm gonna treat
you wonderfully but by the way I do all
my tenants right right yeah you just say
it out loud and then if they come in and
ask for something unreasonable you say
no I meant we talked about this you're a
tenant in the property tenants don't get
to ask for stuff like you're asking for
is not cause you're my cousin no you
didn't listen when you moved in when you
moved in here's what we said and you go
back to that but if you don't have that
conversation ahead of time you can
expect them to have a sense of
entitlement about something by being
family somewhere in the process if you
don't set the table ahead of time
alright great thank you thank you
if you clearly define the roles you can
do business with family but you have to
clearly define the roles I'll give
another example my cousin Marshall
Ramsey is a world-class illustrator
Pulitzer prize-nominated twice he isn't
editorial cartoonist Jackson Mississippi
and does incredible work he is
unbelievably talented and the first
round of the junior series books heated
the illustrations in them family you
know what he got paid for doing those
illustrations
he's like we would have paid any other
illustrator and you know when we paid
the royalties checks
perfectly on time like we would have any
other illustrator and we sold a bunch of
those books and he got some pretty
decent roll teas out of it when we redid
the books we changed the illustrator
because we wanted a different look and
so he's not in that loop anymore just
like I would have changed any other
illustrator because I wanted a different
look wasn't cause he did a bad job it
wasn't because I was mad at him because
he's family matter of fact we're not mad
at each other at all we like each other
a lot we have a lot of respect for each
other but we just did a business
transaction and kept it all up at that
level where he didn't get a worse deal I
didn't get a worse deal we didn't get
any extra special treatment
except he probably got his foot in the
door to start with to do that you know
because he's my cousin and I happened to
know him you know I known one of my
buddies from college he would've got his
foot the door to do that to the same
thing right but still you've got to
perform in the transaction on both sides
of the transaction with an ethical
excellent way and for you know thank
goodness Marshall did and I did and we
were able to do that transaction he was
able to make a little money we were able
to get some wonderful illustrations and
when they ended we were still friends
and still cousins and it's all good but
we had this clear expectation that we
weren't going to mistreat one another
because we were family or expect
something different because of your
family we both had to bring the water
and when you do that when you do that
anytime you work on the family you can
have a wonderful experience and lots of
people can do that but these experience
are only as functional as your family is
to the point that your family's crazy
then you're going to have trouble with
that you know and every family's got
some crazy in it and if you think
there's not crazy and your family it's
you hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
now
[Applause]
[Music]